Wow!
Hello, everybody!
Hello!
We have a special guest here today that's gonna help me cook.
And teach you guys how to cook with 10 microwaves.
Can you guys count them right now?
10 micro... I feel like Dora the Explorer right now.
Vambanos, everybody!
Can you see 10 microwaves, chat?
How many microwaves are there?
1... 2... 3... 4... 5... 6... 7... 8... 10!
10 microwaves!
Hello!
We have a special guest here today that's gonna help us cook with our 10 microwaves.
Why don't you introduce yourself?
Hi, so my name is Tim and I am the microwave cook.
Yes.
As you might have seen, the tomato sacrificed his life for us to be here.
Oh wait, you're wearing him!
You're right!
You're wearing that tomato gas!
So, this is...
And today, we're gonna prove that microwaves can do anything!
Whoa!
Anything?
What do you have planned for us, Tim?
We're gonna fry with it?
We're going to cook a whole chicken?
Wait, you can fry with Tim?
You can fry with microwaves?
I thought you just pressed start.
That's what we're gonna do.
Okay, what else are we gonna do, Tim?
I'm gonna cook a whole chicken.
You're gonna cook a...
We're gonna...
You know what?
We're gonna get started with that right now!
Wait, isn't that chicken raw?
Wait, is that healthy?
Is that sanitary?
Tim's kinda...
Don't worry, guys.
I've upped Tim a little bit.
Don't worry.
I'm a professional.
You're a professional?
Wait, do you have a degree?
Wait, what are you doing?
What are you doing right now?
Technically!
Why are you putting cows on top of a chicken?
Technically, I do have a degree.
I did actually graduate from culinary school.
And then cooked at a Michelin-style restaurant.
With a microwave?
Technically, yes.
No, look.
They hated microwaves when I was cooking.
And... and...
Wait, which restaurant so I know not to go?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
You'll see.
I'm just saying, I didn't pay $80 for a microwave meal.
Like, I might as well eat it at home.
So, today, I'm gonna prove that microwaves are so underrated.
And it is going to cook a perfect chicken.
We're even gonna crisp salmon skin with it.
What?
And we're also...
We're gonna make kainani's chicken rice.
We're gonna make salmon.
We're gonna make clam chowder.
What?
We're gonna make lobster.
Lobster in a microwave?
Also dessert.
Will you eat it live on stream, too?
Uh-huh.
And I'm gonna feed those guys.
Oh, nice.
You're gonna feed your camera crew.
Wait, is this an information?
Hey, y 'all are on insurance, right?
I hope they are.
So, this whole chicken...
Yeah?
...is gonna go in the microwave.
And I'm gonna start it now because it's gonna take 40 minutes.
Wait.
We're gonna...
What?
So, what you do...
What you do with this is...
The reason why we're covering with a paper towel is because the way microwaves work...
Uh-huh.
...is they basically...
They basically beam the microwave energy down into the water.
And then the water just vibrates really fast.
And that's what makes it hot.
Oh!
When it vibrates really fast, it gets heat.
Just like how friction will cause heat.
And then, because of that, the water will start to steam out.
Oh!
And if we wrap paper towels around it, then it won't escape.
And it'll keep everything moist.
I'm not gonna season this right now.
We'll do that later.
If I season it right now, it might actually...
But if we...
The temperature of it would shorten the time to do the chicken?
Yes.
Actually, microwaves are one of the most efficient ways to cook.
Almost 100% of the energy goes directly into the food.
So...
Can we shorten it to like 20 minutes?
Um, yeah.
Technically, with a microwave powerful enough.
Yeah.
Which actually...
Do we have that?
At the...
Yes.
At the Vite facility.
We have an industrial microwave that I actually built myself.
Oh!
That's what DIGs are noodles.
Bring it!
Oh my God!
Wait!
Bring it!
I want to add that into our cooking show!
Add that in!
Next time...
Next time we'll cook...
You don't have your industrial microwave here?
What's the point of bringing 10 microwaves and you don't have the best microwave?
What?
Okay.
So...
A little...
A little secret...
Okay.
I'm actually going to toss this in real quick because it's going to take 40 minutes.
But...
A little secret...
Oh, I love the microwaves, guys.
A little secret about...
I'm just going to have to keep resetting this, I think.
Yeah, we're just going to...
A little secret about how we prototyped before we actually built the industrial microwave.
And the reason I have so many here right now is because...
Is that 20 minutes?
Oh, yeah.
Why do you have so many microwaves here?
Before we could test with the real regular microwave.
Or with the industrial microwave.
Uh-huh.
We tested with 20 small ones to see if it would work.
So, some of these have had their insides gutted out and everything.
And then built back together.
Oh!
Wait.
That doesn't sound safe.
Wouldn't the radiation escape from the microwaves?
So, microwave radiation is actually one of the safest kinds.
It is like visible light.
Yeah.
Just like how...
Just light doesn't hurt you.
Unless you're a gremlin.
Which doesn't go outside.
Then it might hurt you a little bit.
But otherwise, the microwaves...
The only thing it will do is make you warm.
But what if we had 20 microwaves running at the same time?
Is that still safe?
Hey, you want to run all 10 microwaves at the same time?
Do we have all the water in here?
I'm sure.
Okay.
Let's do it.
We're gonna run.
I mean, I'm not the one that's gonna get cancer.
Oh my god, guys!
He's gonna give us entire crew cancer!
That's so fucked up!
All right.
If the power blows out, then...
Yeah.
I already got paid, guys, if the power blows out.
That's fine for me.
All right.
So we're gonna cook that chicken over there.
And this one, we're gonna make Hainanese chicken rice.
And we're also gonna make rice in the microwave.
Everything is gonna be done.
And we're gonna be doing this with the Doki Blade.
Yeah!
By the way!
Oh, so he forgot to...
By the way, we forgot to say this is...
This is a collab with White Robin!
Look at that!
That's my blade!
The Doki Blade!
We forgot the most important part of the introduction.
Look at that there!
They have iron sights, guys!
Isn't that cool?
You can technically throw your knife accurately at people.
I mean, at food.
That's what I mean.
At food, guys.
Show them the iron sight, Tim!
Do you see the iron sight, dragons?
Do you see the iron sights?
Oh, that looks sick.
But yeah, it has my signature and everything, too.
Alright.
Oh, my gosh.
Are you okay?
Oh, it's...
It's just gonna drop a lot.
Alright.
So, we're gonna go...
We're gonna go and break down this chicken.
Uh-huh.
And then we're gonna poach it in the microwave and use the sock in order to cook the rice.
Okay.
And normally, it would take a really long time to cook the chicken, right?
But...
And we're just gonna go fast.
I'm just gonna cut down the backbone over here.
Right?
We have the neck.
Yeah.
And we're just gonna break it down into parts.
So, joint here.
Cut.
Ooh!
Guys, look at that professional go.
Boom.
Here's your wing.
Look how sharp my blade is, guys!
You can get it right now.
The white ramen shop.
Look at that.
Look at...
You can do that to your chicken, too.
This guy cooks.
I know.
Look at him go.
Right?
And then make sure we wanna get the oyster over here.
In the back.
One, two.
Cut.
Ooh!
Pop that joint.
Cut.
And cut.
Boom.
There's your side and leg.
He knows how to cut a chicken.
Boom.
Make sure we get the oyster.
So, this over here in the back is called oyster.
This is basically the tenderloin of the chicken.
And this is known as the chest treat.
Yep.
Wait, why is it called oyster?
If that's a chicken?
Because it looks like an oyster, I guess.
I actually don't know.
Yeah.
Here's what it looks like.
Zoom.
Zoom in on that cameraman.
Cameraman.
Zoom.
Zoom in.
Guys, he's...
I think your cameraman got cancer or something because he's not zooming.
Terrence!
From the radiation.
There we go.
I think...
I think your cameraman may or may not have got hit by the radiation.
That...
Terrence!
Terrence, are you okay?
That does not look like an...
You know what that looks like?
That sort of...
Wait, why isn't he wearing gloves?
Wait a minute.
Why isn't Tim wearing gloves?
What?
Because gloves...
Because gloves are actually- Fun fact.
Did you know that gloves actually spread more food-borne illness than not wearing gloves?
But that's what the cafeteria ladies wear.
Yeah one of the biggest...
Of the biggest issues with...
One of the biggest issues with wearing gloves.
Is people wear the gloves and then don't wash their hands.
Because they can't feel all the stickiness and stuff on the thing.
Well-washed, clean hands are significantly better than gloves.
And that's actually one of the biggest problems in foodborne illness.
When people forget to wash their hands because of...
Wait, that's how people get food poisoning?
Yeah, a lot of times.
And this is especially in fast food, where people will wear gloves, and then they go to the bathroom, and then they don't change their gloves.
Wait!
Yeah, but if you...
Wait a minute!
That sounds bad!
Yeah, not great!
And so that's why a lot of gloves, a lot of incidents of foodborne illness just tend to be from people wearing gloves, and not forgetting to change it.
But if you go to the bathroom, and then you're not wearing gloves, then, well, hopefully most people will know, you're supposed to wash your hands.
Oh, guys, remember, wash your hands.
You can handle your food without wearing gloves, guys.
Just remember to wash your hands.
What the fuck was that?
I felt... Oh, that's your earpiece.
It's like, oh my god, the chicken had black things inside it.
I don't think that's the safe chicken.
What the hell is beeping?
Oh!
Your 20 microwaves?
My 20 microwaves.
Guys, I think this Tim guy's a poser.
How does he not know what a microwave beep sounds like?
I'm just so used to it.
The microwaves are just there all the time.
They're like little lullabies, right?
When they beep all the time, that's what puts me to sleep.
That's how I sleep.
That's the secret of good sleep, by the way.
Get 10 microwaves, run them all for a minute, and just let the beeps put you to sleep.
Oh, yeah, run them all in your room, right?
Make sure it lines up all your walls, too, and have it, like, face your bed when you're heading to sleep.
Including your industrial microwave.
Absolutely.
So, what we're going to do is we're going to make Hananese chicken.
Yay!
I love Hananese chicken.
So, we're going to put all the dark meat in here, so that it doesn't, uh, um, uh, because the, the, well, actually, you know what?
Fuck it.
Everything's going in.
That's fine.
Wait, why fuck it?
Wait a minute.
Are you, are you half-assing this?
Are you half-assing the food?
The titties are too big.
Oh.
I was going to say, we're going to put everything in, but the titties are too big, so.
Oh, no.
Oh, Matt's a busty chicken.
Yeah, right?
She lived a good life.
Oh, my God.
All right.
So, what do we have to do?
All right, Toki.
Do you like thighs?
You, you, you like thighs or breasts better?
I think, like, why not both, you know?
Why, why, why pick when you can have two at the...
That's why God gave us two arms.
And two hands.
One on each part.
All right.
And the important thing, after handling raw chicken, you wash your hands.
Yeah.
All of this, it gets washed.
Okay.
That's the important part.
He's washing, guys.
Now we know that he's not going to give people food poisoning, because he's washing his hands, Chad.
And I got to turn off all the microwaves.
So we're going to go ahead and put a lot of water in this.
And then we're just going to go ahead and microwave it.
And that's going to give us chicken stock.
Because the microwave does not go very quickly, or it doesn't overheat.
We have no problems with burning, and it will cook it nice and gentle and give us that nice poach that Hai Nani chicken rice deserves.
Oh, is that for like the rice?
That's for the rice, yeah?
Yup.
So we're going to make that stock in here, with the water.
Yeah!
Can you make rice in a microwave?
Yup, and that's what we're doing right next.
We're going to make rice!
Guys, I told you, we don't need a rice cooker.
Do you not have a rice cooker?
We don't need a rice cooker, guys!
Oh my god.
All I need is a microwave!
We're going to learn today, Chad!
Shut the open.
Hang on.
We're going to learn today.
Oh my god.
No, he literally said we don't need our rice cooker, Chad.
We can do this.
He's proving... Oh look, there's a doki board!
Yep.
It's right there.
So we're just gonna go ahead and, you know, because this is all going in the same place anyway.
We're gonna go...
Scallions, uh...
Scallions, I'm just gonna go with a shallot over here.
You'll note that I'm still being very careful with how I do this.
Close this so you guys can actually see.
And then, uh...
Here, let's show off the uh... let's show off the knife a little bit.
I'm gonna do a boom walk.
So this is the fancy chef shit.
Oh my god, can anyone do the fancy chef shit?
Yeah, you just gotta practice a lot and then your chefs yell at you a lot until you cry enough and...
Yay!
Abuse is okay sometimes, guys.
You heard that from Tim.
Wait, well...
Abuse works.
ENDORSED BY TIM, THE CEO OF VITE RAMEN, BY THE WAY.
I'M BEING FRIENDS!
I'M BEING FRIENDS, GUYS!
Look at him!
And then you can do fancy shit like this!
You know, in retrospect, having everything be all chickeny and slippery was not the best idea.
That's good!
Wait, but at least it's good food.
Look at that, guys!
His...
His boss yelled at him, so now he can do this.
This is not the best.
Not the best food in the world.
It's fine.
We're talking...
We're chucking it in.
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah, that knife is so sharp, guys.
That's a real Doki blade.
Yeah, I can't even shave with it.
Wait, really?
Do it right now.
Can you get this?
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Can I get band chat if he...
Guys, don't do this at home!
Guys, for legal...
Listen, he is a professional!
Do not do this at home!
Wait, are you gonna wash the knife before you cut more?
Yes!
Yes, I'm gonna wash the knife before I cut more!
What?
Nice!
The seasoning is Tim's hair, guys.
Yeah.
The extra seasoning.
A lot of...
Look, hey, Doki, look.
A lot of people would pay extra for that, okay?
Wait.
A lot of people would pay extra for that.
Is that what you did at your Michelin star restaurant, too?
Yeah, absolutely.
Actually, uh...
But you add these secret ingredients and you start shaving your arm.
Little known fact, we actually started...
We actually started...
Pioneered the OnlyFans model of Michelin star restaurants.
Ooh!
Where we would...
You know, we would do all kinds of stuff.
Or we'd include body parts and other things upon request.
Oh, it's like those like...
It's like those sexy firemen calendars.
You did like...
Like sexy Michelin chef...
OnlyFans.
Okay.
Unironically though...
Unironically though, I had to make Michelin star dog food once.
Wait, really?
How do you make Michelin star dog food?
Yeah.
Um, I don't know.
I just like did a brunoise...
I just like did a brunoise of like a bunch of vegetables and like beef and stuff.
And then...
Oh my God.
And then just like...
Saltate it and went...
Here it is for your dog, I guess.
Oh my God.
Listen to these microwaves beep.
So beautiful.
And then...
Remember...
So that's...
So I have a disinfectant right here that I use.
Yeah.
And that's what I'm gonna use to disinfect it and get everything.
Yep.
This is a quad sanitizer.
So you'll usually find this in a red bucket at restaurants.
Yeah.
And it disinfects basically everything.
It's the standard disinfectant that's used.
Can you spray it on food?
No.
It tastes really bad.
But like...
But you...
But it still disinfects it, right?
So if you...
If you drop food...
If you drop food on the floor and then you spray it, will it disinfect the food?
I...
Yeah.
Technically.
Could you try that out for me?
Oh my god.
Oh guys.
Crazy.
He did it.
See guys.
It works.
Don't try this at home.
But if you drop something...
If you drop something really, really good...
You can disinfect...
According to Tim and endorsed by Tim, the owner and CEO of Vite Ramen...
What?
Stop!
No!
I'm spitting it out.
Don't...
Don't sue me.
All right.
Anyway.
So what's the next plan?
So...
I'm just peeling some ginger.
Yeah?
The fastest way and easiest way to peel ginger by the way is...
With a spoon.
Uh huh.
And we're just gonna...
Ah, my god.
Okay.
You know what?
I give up with that one.
I hope you can still hear me.
It keeps falling out of my ear.
My ear is not made for that.
I think one of your ear holes is too big.
It's true.
You need to have a bigger earbud for that.
The problem is... The hole is too big.
Yeah.
Sometimes I just jam a lot of stuff in my ear.
You know, when you jam the right things into your ear and it just feels really good and you can't stop.
Yeah.
All right.
So what's the next plan for this meal?
I'm pretty sure we're behind schedule too.
Whoa!
I don't know how we got behind schedule, guys.
We're not behind schedule.
All right.
And then we're just going to... we're going to go with a little yellow wine.
Yeah?
We're going to go yellow wine here.
Ooh.
And then we're going to go... where'd my soy sauce go?
And then I have a little bit of soy sauce.
I'll have to blur that.
Joki, don't stress him.
He's used to it.
He used to work at a restaurant.
I'm his Gordon Ramsay.
Guys, where's my MSG?
Oh my god, MSG, we can't forget the MSG.
How do you not know where it is?
Throw it, throw it, throw it, throw it!
Whoa!
Good!
Oh my god, that's a lot of MSG.
Oh my god.
No, that's the right amount of MSG.
You're right, that's the right amount of it.
There's no such thing as not enough.
Or too much.
There's no such thing as too much MSG, guys.
All right, that's probably good.
That's... yeah.
Whoa!
So, we got shallots, we got... oh man, I didn't...
You forget something?
Yeah, we're just gonna throw some garlic in there real quick.
Oh, I love garlic!
That's some good-ass chicken.
For the, uh...
And this is actually the hardest recipe.
The other stuff actually, it goes even faster.
Whoa, wait, this is the hardest recipe?
Yep.
Wait, what makes it hard?
The fact that I gotta prep so much stuff.
Oh!
I gotta make my ancestors proud, you know?
Oh, true, true.
Like how you ate a shallot off the floor, I bet they're real proud.
Yeah, I'm sure they are.
Because an anime girl told you to, I bet they're looking down on you right now.
Hey, look, look, look.
I'm sure my ancestors also would've eaten food off the ground if an anime girl told them to.
They just didn't know it.
Great, great crap, are you hearing me?
You're right, you're right.
He doesn't waste food.
I know you were part of the Church of Thydeology.
You're...
Whoa!
Wait, the guys check my channel, not yours.
Guys, if Scientology is watching right now, I...
No, Thydeology.
Oh, Science...
Thy...
Thydeology, come on!
Oh,醒ology, okay.
It's all about theoricis.
Oh, yeah, yeah, growingci...
Yeah, we're...
You know what?
We're talking about food here, we're talking about, uh...
We're talking how about...
The chickens, yeah.
We're talking about Thy이지.
Fiology, guys.
Not the other things.
God.
Yeah.
You know, like...
Thy´好 всем, right, guys?
Exactly.
Is theology, you guys, nothing else.
There's no other ol...
Olologies out there.
The perfect religion.
Yeah, its yeah.
You all gotta read, uh...
You'll all gotta read..
The Holy Thigh-Val?
Whoa, what's in it?
Who's the god of the Holy Thigh-Val?
You know, anyone with a bunch of thighs.
Yeah, but there has to be one true thigh.
Who's the one true thigh?
So that's where you get into the different denominations.
What if you accidentally cut your finger while we're talking about...
Then I'm just gonna have one less finger and we're still gonna stream, right?
We're still gonna stream.
The close-up on your fingers while you try to think of the one true thigh.
That's the pressure right there.
The show must go on, you're right.
You can't put me on the spot like that.
Like, there's a lot of good thighs out there.
There's a lot of good thighs.
Oh, really?
What are you...
I told you, guys, he's thinking about the thighs too much.
Guys, don't... don't handle knives when you're thinking about thighs, Chad.
Or things like...
No, I disagree.
Always think about...
When you think about... What, you want to cut a piece of that thigh?
Oh my god.
It's a professional over there.
Look at him go.
Holy shit.
It's like, look, if you think about thighs, you won't get cut.
Oh my god.
That's so much pressure.
The fucking stress and... stress of watching this.
Oh my god.
That's what you know he's a professional.
Look at that knife go.
You can get... you can pre-order this knife right now.
Pinned in my cat.
I'm so... I'm so glad you're shilling well.
I suck at shilling.
You can buy that knife right... the Doki Blade right now and pre-order it at Vite Ramen Shop.
Pinned... the link is pinned in the description, guys.
We're also going to make some... oh, I'm going to do this later because this isn't... this is not a microwave thing.
But now, we're also going to make some salmon.
Oh my god.
I never started this.
Oh no.
We're behind schedule, guys.
What are you going to do?
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
I'm worrying.
We don't do the wrong.
Guys, let's worry too and put more stress on him.
Let's remind him what it was like in that Michelin star restaurant chat.
Give me another chance.
Yes, Chef.
Yes, Chef Doki.
Okay.
I got it.
Five minutes on salmon, Chef.
Five minutes on salmon.
We're just going to... yeah.
Oh my god.
You have the three over here.
That's it.
Right?
Okay.
And then... hey, you want the salmon on the Western style?
You want Western style or you want Eastern?
Oh, that's hard.
Can we do half-half?
Yeah, we'll do half-half.
Yeah.
We're going to do this on one half.
We're going to go MSG on everything.
Oh my god.
That's a lot of MSG.
And we're going to go yellow wine on one side.
And then the middle side is just going to be like the mix of everything, you know?
Yeah.
Oh, so it's like fusion.
Oh, it's a fusion!
Yeah.
And then we have tomato?
Whoa!
Look how sharp that is, guys.
Oh my...
He's missing.
Use your iron sight, Tim.
Use the iron sight.
That's the whole thing.
You're right.
I hit it.
I keep hitting it.
I'm just saying.
All right.
Buying a Doki blade does not make you aim better, Chad.
I'm sorry.
I think Tim has proven that for us.
Doki, you're supposed to tell them and do some aimbot!
Well, how am I supposed to lie if you don't upheld...
If you don't help me, lie with me!
I can't lie if you can't...
If you can't prove my lie correctly!
We'll edit the...
We'll edit...
We'll edit in post!
Yeah, we'll edit this...
We'll edit this livestream in post, guys.
Yeah.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, you're right.
Increases accuracy, but does not improve aim.
You're so right.
Tim's aim was actually much worse than that, guys.
His accuracy increased because of the knife.
So, if you thought that that was bad, imagine what he was like before he used the Doki blade.
Like...
Can your knife do this?
Yeah, can your knife do this?
Whoa!
Can your knife do that?
Look at that!
Before he used the Doki blade, he missed all those shots.
True, true, true, true.
Look at that.
Whoa!
That's some good-ass cutting right there.
Um...
I don't know what I was going to do with this.
What was I going to do with this?
You're going to make a fusion.
Yeah, okay.
Okay.
We're going to put this on one side.
Yeah.
That's fine.
It'll taste good.
Wait.
What do you mean?
I thought you were confident.
I thought you were a Michelin chef.
Wouldn't everything you cook be good?
Yeah.
I improvised everything.
Oh!
That's so true.
Yeah, look at that.
We're going to also go with some garlic over here.
You just got to go garlic, shallots, ginger.
Not just go through everything, right?
You should add more MSG on top of all of that.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah, yeah.
You should.
Ooh.
That's...
That's his white powder, guys.
Dude, this one's gonna...
This one's gonna break by the time this is over.
Yeah.
Right?
We're just gonna throw some...
We're just gonna throw the...
Some garlic in there.
Just a quick peel.
Nice, simple.
Simplastic!
Okay.
And then that's it.
And then...
And then it's microwave time.
And this will give you perfect tender salmon every single time.
The towel!
Yup.
It's the towel trick!
Slap it in.
Microwave time!
Yippee!
And this...
Uh, we'll go for six minutes and then we'll check it.
Six minutes?
In the microwave?
Yup.
And that's pretty much all you need.
If we just had one, it would be even faster.
Ooh!
I didn't put the ginger in.
You know what?
That's fine.
Don't worry about it.
It's fine.
Ginger doesn't even taste that good.
Whoa!
I thought...
They don't have soles anyway.
It doesn't matter.
Oh!
Wait!
Hang on!
So true, right chat?
So true!
All right.
What...
So, what we're actually going to do with some of these...
So, we are going to use a technique called Konkase as well.
Yeah?
We're also going to do...
What was that?
We're going to go ahead and...
Well, actually, no.
I'm going to go ahead and first make our...
Um...
We're going to make our, uh...
Tomato rice.
Oh my god!
We can...
Guys, he's going to show us how to microwave a rice!
You'll never have to buy a rice cooker again!
So, we lightly score.
Yeah?
We lightly score over here, which you can't do if you have a shitty knife.
You're going to just stick it right on top.
You don't need a tomato to be...
To be clear.
But it'll taste better.
You do not need a tomato to do that.
Yeah.
But it'll taste better.
Because tomatoes have a lot of umami.
Oh!
What does that mean?
What does umami mean?
Umami is savory flavor.
Uh-huh.
It is...
It is the stuff that makes your brain go...
Mmm.
When you taste something.
Oh!
And, uh...
So...
Tomatoes have a lot of it.
That's why we're putting it in pretty much everything.
Oh!
This, uh, right here...
We scored on the top.
And we're going to microwave it.
So that it will, uh, split apart.
And then we're going to peel it and get the skin out.
So that...
We have a skin.
Just like this tomato skin I'm currently wearing.
Oh!
That's so cool, guys.
Are you taking notes?
Wait, why was there water in that other microwave?
Um, because you can't run a microwave dry.
Otherwise, it will burn.
Oh!
Yep.
So what happened?
So if you just had nothing in that microwave, and you just press it, it'll, like, explode?
It...
Yes.
It will...
It will, uh...
How do you know that?
Have you tried it before?
Um, yes!
Actually, when I was doing my industrial microwave, I nearly died two times.
Whoa!
You lived?
Right?
Isn't that cool?
How did you live?
Yeah, I nearly got electrocuted and died.
Wait, what?
A skill issue.
A skill.
Wait, how?
Wait, wait.
Okay, there's a lot to unpack there.
So, um...
So, like, what did you do?
I was building...
I was building the micro...
Industrial microwave.
We needed to test voltages.
And it...
It...
And my dad was like, oh, yeah, no, you should just, like, put the wire over there.
I'm like, dad, there's, like, 200 amps running through that right now.
And he's like, it's okay, I'll just hold this aside with a screwdriver.
And I'm like...
Wait, your dad endorses this?
You're...
He doesn't like to talk about it.
Your dad...
You're...
Yeah.
Yeah, just a little family project of, you know, nearly electrocuting and dying.
Don't worry about it.
It's fine.
Okay, so what happened after that?
So, uh, what happened after that was, uh, I...
Oh my god, I didn't start this.
I need to remember to start things.
What happened after that was, um, it actually shocked...
This was during...
This was during production.
So, while...
While we were making noodles, we were testing the microwave because it was a new build.
Yeah.
And then, uh...
And then...
He put...
He pushed it aside.
And then I tried to put a little bit of things in there.
Uh-huh.
Uh...
And then his screwdriver slipped.
It slipped and then all the...
All the wires came together all at once.
And there was a flashbang.
And then suddenly, I couldn't see.
I couldn't hear.
I couldn't feel anything.
And I was sitting there going, Am I dead?
Is this what death is like?
What a way to go.
And then my ears started ringing.
And then my eyes started to get back.
And then my dad is sitting there shocked going...
Oh my god.
And then my entire production crew is sitting there going...
Because it was a loud bang and flash.
Yeah.
And they're all looking going...
Oh my god.
Is he dead?
And I'm just sitting there going...
Hey, Dad, why don't we not measure this?
And he was like, nah, okay.
Yeah, that's like, someone was like, that's basically a small lightning strike at point blank.
Yup.
Wait, did you get... did you see a doctor after?
Absolutely not.
Yeah, I was gonna say, you're American, right?
Whoa!
What's that supposed to mean?
But you're actually right!
Oh my God!
Wow!
Rude!
Rude, but true!
Alright, now we're gonna start making the clam chowder.
I'm gonna go ahead and peel potatoes for that.
What?
Health medical calls are expensive!
They're expensive over there!
It's like, it's like, like, four digits for a fucking ambulance, guys!
For you non-Americans out there!
What do you mean, four?
Wait, is it five digits?
Last time.
Right?
Yeah!
Ten thousand dollars!
Oh my God!
Ten thousand dollars for an ambulance ride sometimes!
Five digits, guys!
To get an ambulance ride for you non-Americans out there!
My comment is true!
They booed her because she was right!
Okay, so what are you doing right now?
Yeah!
So, I'm making, uh, I'm gonna make some clam chowder with a microwave.
Mm-hmm!
And so, I'm just, uh, I'm just cutting the, uh, the potatoes.
We're just gonna do a nice cube.
Whoa!
And, uh, after we do a nice cube, then we're just gonna...
Oh God, do I have another big container?
Ah, we'll figure it out.
Wait, are you gonna bring another container?
What happens if you just put it in without a container?
Would it still...
Um...
You just put it with paper towel.
Yeah, but it'd get all over the microwave plate.
Yeah, I, I...
I mean, you have ten microwaves, does it really matter?
I do!
I do have ten microwaves!
Does it really matter if one microwave gets dirty when you have ten microwaves?
I bet...
Yeah, see?
Wait, actually, wait, actually, here, I can just put it in the water.
Actually, that would make more sense.
Oh.
Wow, look at us, using our brain cells.
I know, right?
Our singular brain cells together.
Hey, Donkey, can I borrow the brain cell today?
No, we're gonna have to share this.
Donkey, can I borrow the brain cell today?
Dammit!
We're gonna have to share this and want to get through today's stream.
Man!
Mom always says that you get to use the brain cell!
I wanna use it!
Cause mom's right.
There's a reason why.
Whoa!
What is that supposed to mean?
So we're gonna cook that.
And then, uh...
Oh my god, do I have my mía pois?
Yeah.
And we also have our celery, right?
Ooh!
Oh my god, look at him go!
And, uh, that's...
So that's how you...
Yeah?
Sorry, my face is covering me.
That's how you cut celery in a Michelin star restaurant, you know?
Yeah.
Perfect.
You know, that's perfect right there.
Wait.
And then you gather it all up.
Yeah.
Wait, but like...
Yeah, so that...
Yeah, this is how you do it.
Really?
And then the next step...
Yep.
Never order celery, guys.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry, chef!
Chef!
Chef, don't tell me!
Chef, please!
Oh my god!
No, it's like...
Don't worry about it!
Guys, never order celery.
Again.
Right?
And then, uh...
Oh, we're not gonna show that one off yet.
That's...
That's not there yet.
Uh...
Yeah, and then we'll...
Go ahead and put this.
We don't need that much.
Um...
Where'd I put my onions?
Hey guys, did I put the onions over there?
Where did he put the onions, guys?
Staff team!
Onions!
Where's his onion staff?
It's fine.
We're gonna use shallots.
Okay.
Alright, we don't need this much celery.
In fact, too much celery is just gonna not taste that good.
Yeah, I was gonna say, that's a lot of fucking celery.
That's...
Guys, eat your veggies!
I'll use that later in a beer plow or something.
Eat your veggies, guys!
So, we're gonna go ahead and just put this with...
Um...
Oh, wait.
No, actually.
Uh...
So, yeah.
We're gonna use this.
We're gonna use shallots.
So, there's gonna be a pseudo-mirepoix, which is usually, uh, onion, carrot, tomato.
Uh-huh.
Or...
It's gonna be...
Whoa, you got so stressed out to start speaking Chinese, guys.
He...
No!
You got...
Bro, guys, he forgot how to speak English from distress, guys.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry!
He's getting PTSD, guys.
So, we're gonna put the shallots in there as well?
And then we're gonna put some cream?
Where the...
Okay.
Then we're gonna put some cream?
Uh, I am lactose intolerant, but I'm doing this for you guys, alright?
Sweet.
I'm not.
What?
I'm the 1% Asian that's not lactose intolerant.
Oh my god, I can't believe this.
This is bullshit.
I won the genetic lottery, guys.
I need as much cheese and peas I want.
Okay, that's not ready yet.
Almost there.
Keep that one going.
This one.
Yep.
We'll keep that going.
And then, this one.
I think it's actually done.
Ow, that's hot.
Watch me burn myself.
So, a little bit of suffering, right?
Which one was this one?
Oh, that's the salmon.
That's the six-minute salmon.
Salmon!
Oh, is it good?
Yeah, and you can see, this is perfectly cooked.
Wait, I want a close-up of that.
Cameraman, give me a close-up.
Close-up.
Cameraman, I want to see.
Oh, wait, that actually looks good.
Yeah?
Wait.
That looks good.
Let's get a cross-section.
Oh my god, yeah.
This is a microwave salmon, guys.
Wait, you have a knife.
Just cut it.
So, we're going to do another little trick.
Yeah?
This special thing will let us sear and get a crispy bottom of the salmon.
So, we're just going to put this into the microwave.
Yeah?
We're actually going to microwave it for three minutes by itself.
And that will get it really, really hot.
Oh.
And then, let me get, like, a spoon or something.
And we're just going to lift this out.
Yeah?
Without the strength.
Oh my god, it's so tender.
Oh my god, it's falling apart.
Look at that.
That's a tender-ass salmon.
Yeah, you see that?
Yeah.
See that?
We'll get this one on camera so you can see exactly.
Ooh.
Oh, you got, like, a big thing in front, by the way, Terrence.
You got, like, the files for some reason.
The files?
All right.
And then...
Yeah, Terrence, get that shit out of here.
Ooh.
You see that?
You'll see how flicky that is?
Yeah.
You can see how tender that is?
Ooh.
That looks good.
Tender.
Moist.
Juicy.
Eat it.
Ow, it's burning my fingers.
Eat it right now.
Is it good?
Oh, shit, that's really fucking good.
Holy fuck.
Oh, wait, really?
Holy shit.
Oh, you guys want to know this?
Get a guy off the street and tell us the truth.
Oh, is that Terrence?
Yeah, of course.
Terrence, try it.
No, this is Leo.
This is Leo.
Wow, what a flavor.
Yeah.
We doxed Leo.
Let's go.
I need another one.
That was really good.
Yeah, wait, I said put more MSG on it.
Yeah, that was all me, guys.
I said we got to put more MSG.
Let's go.
All right, and then we're going to...
Oh, and then what we're going to do in order to give our lobster a little bit of flavor.
Oh, it's the lobster.
Lobster, yeah.
We're actually going to go ahead and pour the juices of this into here.
Just a little bit.
Yeah.
And then water.
And then, importantly, we want tomato.
Yeah.
This is...
We're going to go tomato, and we're going to go wine.
We're going to go white wine over here.
And this is going to be kind of like...
Why is it in a black box?
Because I can't afford good wine, okay?
I'm just a tomato.
All right?
Say he's a guy with fucking 11 microwaves, guys.
He can't.
Tim, I think maybe if instead of buying, you know, 11 microwaves, maybe you could afford better wine.
You know?
The microwaves are my life.
Look how beautiful they are.
They're so nice.
It all goes into the microwaves.
Oh, my God.
Look how sharp.
We don't need that tomato.
He's a problem, child.
Just like me.
For real, for real.
And, of course, MSG.
Anything savory, we always want to go MSG.
I do have time.
I'm not going to put time out of it.
We're running out of time, guys.
We're running out of time.
It's all right.
We could go a little over time.
We could go.
We've got to make sure that everything's cooked.
No, I mean time.
That's in T-H-Y-M-E.
See, that's...
Time!
You've got to be a chef to understand that joke.
Yeah.
I am going to put it in.
That's a joke for all you chef goons out there.
Did you enjoy that joke, guys?
We've got to do something for everybody.
Oh, I need some garlic in there.
Actually, I don't.
I don't care.
I don't care enough.
Boom.
Like, garlic's good.
I care.
We're going to cook three lobsters.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I care.
Yes, chef.
I'm sorry, chef.
I'm sorry for trying to take sure.
Sorry, chef.
What happened, chef?
You care?
Guys, he doesn't care about you, but I do.
I knew you guys cared about the garlic.
What's that?
What's wrong with the microwaves?
There's so many.
Oh, that's the chicken.
That's the tomato rice?
This is the chicken?
Yeah.
We're going to need another container, and we're going to make our chicken rice chicken.
Oh, chicken rice chicken.
Hello, chicken.
It booms the man garlic.
What's that?
Oh, is that the rice?
Guys, guys, no.
I'm doing it.
Guys, this is the most important part of this entire stream.
Just this part.
Oh, my God.
That smells totally...
Wait, no.
We're streaming.
Okay.
Dude, you guys got to smell this later.
I'm so sorry that you can't.
Guys, he broke out of character.
That's how good it was.
He broke out of character.
That's his CEO voice right there.
That's so good.
Jesus.
Okay.
This, we just got put in the microwave for...
Okay, this one still needs to go.
Which microwave?
Is this one done?
That's not done.
That needs some more time.
What about this one?
This one's clear.
Okay.
This one.
Go.
So, this one, we're going to go 12 minutes.
Wait.
So, okay.
Wait, wait.
How do we do this to make...
So, we put rice in a bowl and then microwave it for 12 minutes and then we get rice?
Yep.
Two to one.
So, you want to do two to one ratio or you can use the old Asian trick.
The old Asian trick.
Oh, let me just show that again with a little bit.
Yeah, yeah.
I need a...
Okay.
So, guys, take notes, guys.
So, you'll never eat a rice cooker.
Yeah.
Right?
Any amount of rice here.
Yeah.
Right?
And what we do is you just add enough water.
Well, this is a small amount of rice, but to go up to that first knuckle over here.
Oh, guys, are you taking notes?
Right?
So, you just...
Yeah.
Sometimes, though, if your hands are like mine and it's a little too big, then you want to go a little under the first knuckle if you have big hands.
But otherwise, usually up to the first knuckle, that's the correct amount of rice.
And make sure you wash your rice!
I don't know which camera's active right now.
Make sure you wash your rice.
Guys, and then you put that in the microwave so you never need to buy a rice cooker again.
Oh, that needs to go a little bit more.
Okay.
And then we're hitting our garlic.
Yeah.
And then we're hitting our garlic so that Chef Toki doesn't yell at me.
That's right.
I'm here to give you PTSD of your great time in the Michelin star restaurant.
All right, look at it go.
You should be honored to be yelled at.
I'm sure people would pay for the privilege, people would pay for the privilege, Chef!
Oh my God, I'm actually out of microwaves.
Oh wait, here, this is perfect.
I was going to say, how are you out of microwaves?
Boom.
I'm out of microwaves!
All right, so this one, it's super super hot, and watch, watch what we do now.
So this one has the skin, okay, the skin's falling off a little bit, don't worry about it.
But, do you hear that?
Yeah.
Oh, the sear!
Yeah!
It's sizzling!
And so, and so what we can do here is, this is a microwave plate, it sears it, and so we want to start it again, and then we'll microwave.
That one's probably going to be a little bit overcooked because I forgot to take it out a little early.
But you know, that's fine.
You guys can't tell on camera.
Yeah, but we heard the sizzle.
We heard it.
Yeah!
Look at this.
Oh!
Look at that.
That looks good.
Oh.
What is this for?
Ah!
Ha ha ha!
Oh, it's hot.
So what is this chicken for?
Yeah.
This is for the Ahayonee chicken rice.
Oh!
And we're going to do a, we're going to do a flash infusion.
Okay, you know what?
That's, that's too, we're going to put this aside for now.
Because I'm burning my fingers.
Ow!
And so we are going to do a flash infusion.
What does that mean?
Okay, so, so normally, you know you get the sauces in Ahayonee chicken rice, right?
Yeah.
Normally, that would take quite a while in order to do.
But here, we're going to make a garlic, we're going to make a garlic, garlic and scallion infusion in just three minutes.
Whoa, three minutes?
Yep.
How long does it usually take?
So...
Like 30 to 40 minutes.
Whoa!
Wait, how are you doing that?
How are you making it three minutes?
So, microwaves, microwaves, I talked about it earlier, but microwaves don't actually heat up, microwaves only do polar things, which is, which means that it will only heat up water-based things.
It does not heat up oil-based things.
Wait, so why don't people cook with microwaves instead of like the fucking boring way?
That's what I'm saying!
The long boring way.
This is like actual...
This is more speedrunning, guys.
We're speedrunning cooking right now.
Look at how many things I'm able to make right now.
Wait, can we be on speedrun.com?
I know there's a speedrun for making cookies.
Can we...
Yeah.
Can we register?
No, unironically.
Unironically.
I think if you used a microwave, it would go faster.
Guys, did you guys know there's a speedrun for cookies?
For making cookies?
Nearly on speedrun.com?
Oh my God, we can register this on Cooking Any Percent.
Any percent?
Right here.
Yeah, Cooking Any Percent right here with microwaves.
We're like revolutionizing tech right now.
Hell yeah!
Yeah.
We're fucking...
We're running speedrun techs, guys.
We're just gonna go with oil.
Oh God, I'm out of oil.
It's fine.
Wait, you're running out of oil?
I thought you prepared for this.
Alright, so what's next?
What do we do next?
So...
TikTok three minutes counter.
We're gonna go...
TikTok.
You said three minutes.
Now we're just gonna put...
Now we're just gonna put this in an open mic...
How do I not have any microwaves?
Oh, wait, no.
This one we can't use.
Wait, why can't we use that?
Then that's nine microwaves, you liar.
You know what?
You're right.
I was like...
It's missing a...
You made me clickbait.
It's missing a turntable.
I wrote ten microwaves.
How am I supposed to clickbait if it's false?
Oh.
I don't know.
Every YouTuber seems to do it.
Yeah, but I'm different.
Build different?
I...
I'm build different.
Ten microwaves minus one.
All right, we're gonna keep cooking this?
All right, what's next, Tim?
Oh, God, it exploded all...
I got a white creamy explosion everywhere, guys.
I'm sorry.
Whoa.
Wait, don't, don't, no, shh.
No, no, no.
She's gonna get demonetized.
No, I wanna see.
You wanna see it?
I wanna see.
The white creamy explosion.
Ugh.
Whoa.
Extra creamy.
Extra.
Oh, my God.
What happened?
What?
Oh, that's hot.
What happened?
Why did that happen?
It got too hot and it boiled over.
You know when it gets too...
Yeah.
You know when it gets too hot and steamy and then you get really excited and then it just...
You can't help it and it just kind of...
Gets everywhere.
It happens to everyone, okay?
All right?
It's not just me.
It happens to everyone.
Just in cooking, right?
Yeah, just, yeah.
In cooking, right?
In Minecraft?
Yep, yep, yep.
In Minecraft, yep, yep, yep.
Yeah, nothing else.
Absolutely nothing else.
All right.
So here, now we have...
Now we have all of our starchy water and stuff.
Yeah.
We're gonna put our potatoes in.
So this is how we're gonna be making our...
Ah!
Oh, that's hot.
Ah, that's hot.
Guys, he's in pain for our pleasure, guys.
And then we're also gonna have...
I love streaming.
We're gonna have our clams as well.
We're gonna make our clam chowder.
Right?
And so these are all technically already cooked.
Um...
And then...
And then we have our seasonings and we have our stuff in there.
Oh, no.
That is...
That's gonna explode again.
That's...
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Wait, how is it gonna explode?
Uh, because we're gonna put it back in the microwave.
Oh!
What if you put those film wraps on top of it?
Would that work?
Uh, because...
No, it would...
It would still unfortunately explode.
What?
But there's a cover.
Because the steam would make it explode.
Oh!
Yeah.
Oh, I see.
And here's our salmon.
And yeah, that's...
Oh, jeez.
Ow.
Don't touch hot plates, guys.
That's...
Yeah.
Don't do it.
He's gonna do it anyway.
But don't do it, guys.
I'm gonna do it anyway.
For your entertainment.
Buy the Toki Blade.
Help me pay my hospital bills after this stream.
Nor, like, help him pay for his ambulance.
Oh, my God.
Look at that.
Oh!
Oral rice.
Look at that.
Right?
Yeah.
And then what you can do is you can peel away the skin.
Oh!
The skin comes right off.
It came right off.
Just like that.
Ha!
Right?
Yeah.
And then what came here?
Look at all these things we're able to make with the microwave.
And then also, we are going to fry kale chips.
Wait, you can fry in the microwave?
Yup.
Guys, look at that.
You don't even need an air fryer, guys.
You can do this in the microwave, too.
It's all in one.
Where the– You can make rice.
You can use it as a fryer?
That's crazy!
Where's the plastic wrap?
What's the plastic wrap?
Steve!
Terrance!
Where's the plastic wrap?
Terrance took the plastic wrap!
Where is it, Terrence?
All right.
All right, we're out of... we're gonna use a nice olive oil.
Oh, nice.
That's some good-ass shit in my microwave.
Mmm, that's some good shit right there.
All right, so watch this.
What you can do is, number one, you need to get good quality plastic wrap, so this stuff will not melt in the microwave until you get it to very, very high temperatures.
And so, you know, Costco ones.
And then all you gotta do, you have your leafy greens like kale, right?
Yeah.
I'm not using an optimal container for this, so we're just gonna pretend like it's optimal.
Wait, you can only do two at once?
Okay, look, if I had a better container, but I'm out of containers.
Okay?
Sorry, Chef.
I'll just have to do it faster, Chef.
Yeah.
And then you rub it with...
You better.
And then you just rub it with oil.
And just oil it up till it's nice and shiny.
Just like that.
And we do a little bit of salt.
That's how I like my kale.
Nice and shiny.
A little bit of salt.
What?
Put MSG.
Hell yeah!
It's the spirit!
Yeah!
She knows!
She knows the tech!
Put that MSG shit on it!
Woo!
MSG!
That's right.
And then this just goes in.
Yeah.
And 30 seconds.
Okay.
Should be enough.
Now what?
Alright, I'm gonna transfer this actually.
Bigger bowl.
Or...
I guess I could...
That's alright.
You...
You can push that as a...
It's a business expense if you break it.
Hot!
Ah!
Whoa!
So...
This is gonna be our clam chowder.
I know the cuts aren't the greatest.
We'll just strain it.
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Wait, guys.
I realize I can...
I can order clam chowder and then I can use...
I can pretend that this is my business expense.
He's making clam chowder, guys.
And then...
Where'd it go?
Yeah?
What do you do next?
Thicken it?
Because...
This isn't thick enough, right?
It's just like...
It's watery.
It's uh...
Yeah.
It's watery.
And we like the...
We like the white stuff.
We like it nice and thick and creamy and really coating.
You really...
When you...
When you put this in your mouth, you really want this to like coat your mouth and like really get, you know, the flavors of that thick creamy white liquid...
Yeah.
Just lingering in the back of your throat.
God damn it!
That's how you want those clam chowders.
That's the chowder in clam chowder.
So what do you do for that?
And so in order to thicken it up, we use cornstarch.
There's lots of...
Secondary use for cornstarch in the kitchen.
Do you know what it is?
What is it?
It's not for food use.
I'll tell you when you're older.
It, uh, unsticks things.
Eh?
No?
No one?
Chat?
All right.
And then now...
It's...
Unsticks what?
You just...
You just drop a little down there.
Unsticks what?
Don't worry about it.
It's my birthday.
Tell me.
I'm already old.
It's my birthday.
Is it?
What is...
What does that mean?
Um...
Uh...
Your, uh...
Your huevos.
Your, um...
Uh...
You know?
Like, um...
Your, uh...
Tomatoes.
In the summer especially.
When the tomatoes are just a little, uh...
A little moist.
You know?
Yeah.
And how many times have you done it?
Don't worry about it.
If you're worried about it, don't be.
Have you concerns?
Unconcern yourself.
Wait, is it for men?
Do you guys do it all the time?
Yes.
At chat, do you do it?
Have you used corn...
Oh, my gosh.
Endorsed fire.
So, if it's sticky, you can unstick it with that.
With cornstarch, guys.
And look at that.
Look at that.
Look at how beautiful that is.
Oh, look at that.
God, I've done it.
So, in just three minutes...
Oh, shit.
In three minutes, we have an infusion.
Oh, man.
That smells amazing.
That's gonna be great for dipping on...
on Hananese chicken rice.
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And we're just gonna set that aside.
And we're just gonna get everything plated.
Someone says, just use baby powder.
Wait, but what's cheaper?
Baby powder or cornstarch?
Well, here's the thing, right?
Cornstarch is a business expense for restaurants.
Oh!
That's true!
If you...
Guys, you can't...
You can't put a tax deductible on baby powder unless you have a baby.
So, this is a bacon just for the clam chowder.
Guys, that's what all the chefs are doing at your Michelin star restaurant.
It's true.
Don't...
Wait.
Wait a minute.
And we wash our hands afterwards.
Just so we're clear.
Don't...
Guys, we know how hot and sweaty the kitchen gets, guys.
Don't order anything with cornstarch at your restaurant.
At your local restaurant, guys.
Don't order anything with cornstarch at your local restaurant chat.
Don't...
Okay.
Look.
There are two containers of cornstarch.
Wait a minute.
One has always marked not for food use for a reason.
I'm never eating again.
You think...
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
But don't eat everything...
Everything has cornstarch.
Oh, yeah.
Never eat, guys.
Maybe we should just start cooking at home instead of eating out.
All right.
Ha, ha, ha.
Look what you did, Tim.
My chat's paranoid now.
They'll never go to a restaurant again.
That they should be.
Wait, actually, reveal to us a deep, dark secret from your Mission Start restaurant days that chefs don't want to tell patrons.
Leak one.
Like a true one.
Don't lie to us.
Reveal the secrets.
So, I would cook plates that were like $50 each, and then I would be making $10 an hour.
And $10 an hour, not including the overtime, we would always be clocking out.
And then going back to work.
And then we would always...
And basically, despite graduating from culinary school, we're going to Mission List our restaurant.
Literally, when I left the shift, I would go get McDonald's because, you know, they didn't feed us either.
And the person working at McDonald's would be making more money than I would.
Wait, what?
On top of that, half the kitchen were externs.
Unpaid externs that flew over from Korea.
What?
Wait, name the restaurant.
Every Michelin star restaurant.
Every single one.
Every Michelin.
Wait, that's so...
Yep.
Wait, what?
So, it was like more so like passion to do that.
Okay, but what about the food though?
Like any deep dark secrets about the food?
Um...
Yeah, there's a... there's a lot more frozen stuff being used in Michelin star restaurants than you would think.
Like what?
And because...
Just...
Uh...
Everything.
From uni to...
Not the uni!
To like...
To shrimp to...
All kinds of stuff.
Because like at the end of the day, things just don't keep that well.
And you can't fly everything over.
Went to a Michelin star restaurant for my birthday!
I paid...
I paid $200!
That sounds good.
For frozen food?
And here!
And then now, check out the scale.
Whoa!
You guys ready to hear it?
Oh!
Getting close.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got scammed guys.
Where is it?
Whoa!
You fried it!
Guys, and it's faster than an air fryer!
Yep!
Look at that!
Oh!
So...
Now we have all this stuff.
Oh!
Let me actually cook this one a little bit more.
That's crispy!
Guys, re-wash the body if you want to make like crispy kale.
Wait, so you would eat like McDonald's nuggies while you're cooking?
Yeah!
Actually, a secret of...
A secret of...
So...
Oh!
Another huge secret is that like...
Everyone assumes that Michelin star restaurants and stuff are eating really well all the time.
Nah!
When we went back home, it was ramen and PB&J.
Like...
We just spent all the time cooking.
We didn't want to cook shit for ourselves.
That's so true though.
That was most common.
Yeah!
Cause you're too tired from cooking.
Yup!
And not only that...
Um...
Not only that, but we would actually, uh...
We...
We wouldn't get like any of the...
We really wouldn't get any of the food over there.
Uh-huh.
Either.
So like...
Sometimes when people would be like, Oh yeah, like, how does this taste?
You'd be like, I don't know, I just make it.
Sometimes...
I would...
At the end of the day, When they had like, tuna they were supposed to throw out.
Because it expired.
I would just like, sneak it.
I would just be like...
Wait, really?
You would sneak...
I mean, it would be good ass tuna though.
To be fair.
It would be good ass tuna.
It is.
Yeah.
You don't want to waste that.
It was expired, but you know, like...
I mean, it's just one day.
You know?
One day expiration date is not that bad.
Expiration dates are suggested, guys.
That's what Tim is trying to endorse.
That's true.
Wait!
Guys, you heard that?
Tim says expiration dates are only a suggestion.
And that's from a culinary expert.
Graduated from cooking school.
All right.
You heard that, guys?
All right, guys.
I'm gonna need you right now to go buy the Doki Blade and the full bundle connection.
Cuz, um...
Yeah?
Mm-hmm.
Lawyers?
Oh, God.
Again?
How many lawsuits?
Yay!
Not on me though!
I'm gonna need you to go buy the collections right now.
Cuz I gotta pay for all these lawsuits.
Yay!
After all the things that you said.
I'm one of those lawsuits, guys.
I'm...
And I'm one of them.
All right.
And what...
And what is food without dessert, right?
Oh, true, true, true.
We...
Oh, God, I...
Do I have a... Yes.
Okay, this is not branded.
Perfect.
So, we're gonna make dessert as well.
Okay.
With our Life is Hard mug.
It's the only non-branded mug I have.
Life is hard.
So, very simple.
We have power?
You buy this when you were a chef too?
Life is hard right now.
Okay.
Flour.
Sugar.
Baking powder.
Yeah.
Vanilla.
Let me wash this so it doesn't taste like chicken.
Uh-huh.
Life is hard, guys.
Look at that.
That's a good-ass mug, actually.
Yeah.
I like that look.
Right?
I feel that, Kat.
Me too.
I feel it.
Cocoa powder?
Yeah.
Ooh.
Chocolate chips.
And then...
Are you taking notes, Kat?
We got...
We got milk.
Oh.
And then butter.
We need it melted.
How do we melt butter, guys?
Microwave!
I feel like...
Doki, you wanna...
You wanna make a microwave?
I feel like we should be selling microwaves right now.
Oh my god, you're right.
A Doki Brandon microwave would go...
Would be so...
So...
Good right now.
That'll fly off the shelves easily.
And then we'll have like a little...
Oh my god.
Guys, wait.
I could have a recipe book for like microwave recipes.
And then I'll have Tim Ghost write it and I'll take all the credit.
We could do that, guys.
Just imagine my branding and...
Oh.
Okay.
And I mean, you're used to it.
You used to work at a Michelin star restaurant.
So you're used to being taking advantage, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yes, Chef.
Yes, Chef Toki.
Thank you, Chef Toki.
And we could have our own microwave recipe book together.
But like, obviously, you're just a ghost writer, though.
Yeah.
I'm nothing, Chef.
Nothing without you, Chef.
Thank you, Chef.
Thank you for giving me this opportunity, Chef.
Yeah.
No problem.
No problem, Tim.
I'm always there for you.
Oh, look at that.
Oh, man.
Look at that.
Look at that lobster.
That looks so good.
And then, important thing about lobster, guys.
Yeah.
You always want to make sure you cut down the middle.
Right?
Uh-huh.
And then, do you see this?
Yeah.
What is that?
I'll take that out.
Oh.
That's the shit sack.
Wait, you don't take it out?
No.
You want to take this out.
This is literally...
Wait, what am I making in here?
Oh, sh...
You want to make sure you...
Yeah.
That's butter.
This is butt...
Yeah.
Get...
Because it's...
It's the butt, it's the, yeah.
And then, so now we have...
That's why you're the ghost writer, Tim.
Oh, look at that.
Look at that.
Look at this lobster.
Hey, Leo, you want to see if you can catch this with your mouth?
What?
You want to catch it with your mouth?
Yeah, Leo.
Leo, do it.
All right.
Three, two, one.
Whoa!
Oh, wait, did he get it?
Wait, no, no, put that sanitizer.
Use the sanitizer.
Yeah, now give it to Tim.
Oh, Leo.
Oh, my God.
Oh, God, that piece of water.
What I said was just a suggestion.
He could have not done that, guys.
It's not my fault.
You could have not done that, guys.
I'm being blamed for all kinds of things right now.
I can't believe this.
What I said was just a suggestion, guys.
Look, now we add all of this into the mug.
Yeah.
And then we microwave it for about three minutes, I think.
Okay.
Look, that's my chopsticks, guys.
You can get those chopsticks right now at the Vite Ramen store.
I have chopsticks, too.
Yeah, that's the sanitizer.
Yeah.
Look, it's right there.
You can check out the shop right now pinned in my chat.
And in the description.
Okay, what's next, Tim?
What's next?
All right.
Now we have dessert.
Uh-huh.
We're gonna start bento plating.
Assuming I have everything done.
Everything's done?
I think so.
Okay.
That's done.
Yeah.
Yay!
That's the chicken.
The 40-minute chicken.
God, that's hot.
I think you might need mittens.
No!
I refuse to it!
I gave him a suggestion and he refused.
See, he does have free will, guys.
Oh my god, did you just put that back in your ear?
Guys, look.
For legal reasons, I didn't tell him to do that.
For legal reasons, that's not on me.
So an interesting thing you'll notice about this chicken is do you see how the skin is actually a little crispy over here?
Yeah.
It's not browned right now because of all the steam, it won't brown.
But if we toss this into the oven for just a little bit or the... which I'm gonna go ahead and do because...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is a microwave only.
Damn it!
You're right!
No, no, no.
The browning is just aesthetic, right?
It doesn't really matter.
There's no shortcuts here.
Yeah, but otherwise, you can see.
Otherwise, we cut into it and you'll see.
Ah, jeez, that's hot.
You can see, that's perfectly cooked.
Look at the juices.
Whoa!
Look at how juicy that is.
Look at that, guys.
Look at the chicken butt.
Yeah.
We like chicken butt here.
Look at that.
Ooh, okay, that looks good.
Oh, oh god.
You're right.
Put the microwave in the oven, so technically it's microwaved.
If you think about it.
For legal reasons, that's also a joke because I don't want to get sued.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, that's really hot.
Okay.
You know what?
We're just going with that.
Yeah?
All right, now.
Now I'm going to go ahead and clean up a little bit so that we can start plating.
Yay!
And we will plate two bentos.
Whoa!
Oh my god, guys.
I'll just go ahead and put this on here for now.
Here's the Doki boy.
I think he's washing you.
It's only on my ear again.
Ah!
It's all right.
You'll be fine.
Ah!
Dammit!
Five-second rule for your ear.
All right.
So what's next, Tim?
So, one of the things...
Next, and now we're finally going to plate with our...
Whoa!
The bento box!
Cute!
Yeah!
Bento box.
Stokey...
Yeah!
That's upside down, by the way.
There you go.
Yeah, there we go!
Yeah, see?
You can also get the bento box, chat!
See you, Dragoons!
It's you guys!
We'll put shit in your head.
Where did I...
I...
Uh...
Okay.
So, what we're gonna do is...
We're gonna go ahead and plate the Hainane chicken rice first.
Uh-huh.
So here, we have our rice.
Yeah.
And, uh...
So, rice.
And we're just gonna...
I'm just gonna put it off to the side over here.
Wait, that looks good.
That's a good-ass bowl of rice.
Right?
Yeah.
Oh my god, that smells so good.
Yes, you...
I'm sorry, you guys can't smell it.
We need... we need smell-o-vision.
Yeah, we need smell-o-vision.
Hey guys, can we...
Can we...
Can we have the smell-o-vision?
At Grok!
Can we like...
When do we have smell-o-vision?
If you can put lingerie on Grok, we can have smell-o-vision.
If we can put lingerie on Grok, we can have smell-o-vision.
Crazy!
That's crazy, Duncan.
We're erasing our resources right now.
For these kind of things, in order to debone it, the nice thing is...
After you...
So, one of the fun things about microwaving, actually, is that...
Because of how the microwaves work, look how easy this is to take off the bone.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, you're so smooth!
Yeah?
Yeah!
Right?
And so we can just...
Right there.
Uh-huh.
And the chicken...
You know what?
The chicken lug we're gonna stick in just as is.
Nice and easy.
And then...
You know, for the other one, we're gonna have a...
So, for this one, we're gonna have a nice mug dessert.
Oh!
For the other one...
And let's get some fresh...
Let's get some fresh green onion in there.
Yeah.
Let him go with the Doki blade, guys.
Whoa!
Look at that guy go!
Ooh!
Look at that!
So fast!
And so sharp!
A little bit on top.
If you cut at a bias like that, then it looks like these little needles, and it looks way fancier.
Ooh!
And then you charge, like, ten dollars more.
Hell yeah!
That's what you do.
It's like how they put these, like...
Yeah, the knife skills.
Those sauces on the plate, for decoration, and then they charge thirty dollars more because it looks a little prettier.
That's how they do it.
Alright, Doki.
Do we put this whole giant tomato there?
Yes.
Wait, would it look nice, though?
Actually, yeah, actually.
Oh yeah, it does!
Look at that!
I think it's gonna be squished a little bit when we actually close the lid.
Yeah.
Oh my god!
Look how fancy those shallots are.
Look at how fancy that is.
Oh yeah, that's also good.
And then, uh, and then, uh, we, we wanna be healthy.
Uh-huh.
So, a single kale chip.
Ooh!
Just one.
Eat your veggies.
Eat your singular veggie, guys.
The singular veggie.
Yeah.
And, of course, we have our infused oil.
So, I'm gonna go ahead and...
Ooh!
That's the, the thing for the chicken.
Yep.
Shallots.
Green onion.
Yeah, guys, you don't wanna be too healthy.
Oh man, that looks good.
That's so true, chat.
True!
If you turn, if you eat too much...
If you're too healthy, you get...
Yeah?
You get what?
If, if you're, if you're too healthy, you get stressed out.
Because you don't eat good food.
And, you know what they say, stress is, stress is the biggest killer.
So, you gotta eat...
That's true.
You gotta...
Why be too healthy when you can just eat McDonald's chicken nuggies like what Tim does?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I don't know, I don't know if that's what we were talking about.
And then, and...
Ta-da!
Look at that.
This nice...
Wow!
Oh, yeah.
And then our mug cake.
Ah, that's hot.
Ah!
Look at that.
And a nice mug cake for dessert.
But, we'll go ahead and scoop that out and then we'll...
Yeah.
I, I significantly overestimated how much space this mug cake would take.
So, we'll, we'll have a little bite.
We'll have a little bite in there.
I can't, I can barely see the cake.
Where is it?
You can barely see the cake.
Whoa!
What do you say?
I do a lot of squats and deadlifts, okay?
Like, I just have Asian genetics.
That's why you can't see the cake as much.
Clearly, I think you didn't do enough.
Sorry, Tim.
It's the truth.
Look at, look, look at that.
Look at that moist cake.
Ooh!
Yes!
Look at that.
Ooh!
Eat it!
Ha!
Oh, man, that's good.
Ooh!
Oh!
Leo!
Redemption art!
The what?
Redemption art?
You're gonna throw cake at him?
Yeah.
Leo, if he...
Blink twice if you wanna...
All right.
If he's abusing you.
Three, two, one.
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Come back here.
One more.
Oh!
Leo was ready for that!
Whoa!
And so we're just gonna put...
Yeah, that was a bad throw.
That wasn't on Leo.
You're so right, Chad.
Yeah, it's true.
It's true.
That wasn't on him.
There we go.
Ta-da!
Zoom, zoom!
Zoom!
I wanna see!
Close-up!
Camera five!
You want, uh...
Wait, I need a better close-up.
Camera five!
Give me that close-up!
Camera two!
I also...
Camera four?
Camera four!
Oh, look at that.
Oh!
The shallots look like a little tomato thing!
Oh, that's cute!
That's cute, guys.
That looks good.
That looks some good-ass chicken right there.
Where's the metal container in this?
I think there's another one over there.
Where did the metal container go?
It's all the way.
We got...
We saw...
We got enough close-up.
All right, what's the second bento?
And then, now, our second bento is...
Camera three!
Second bento tab.
This is...
This is our, uh, clam chowder.
Oh!
Ooh!
Look at how fresh that clam chowder is!
It's got bacon.
Right?
Mm-hmm.
And then...
We got our tomato rice.
Ooh!
On the side.
That'll soak it up.
And this tomato provides a nice little acidity in order to cut through all that cream and fat.
Yeah?
I was gonna do noodles, but people are weirded out by noodles and cream for some reason.
Wait, you can make noodles in a microwave?
Yup!
You want me to do that right now?
Wait, do we have the thing for that?
Yeah!
Uh, can you grab me a...
Uh, I had noodles over there.
Oh.
Wait, how do you make noodles?
Like, cup noodles?
Or, like, actual noodles?
Nope, you can make any...
Yeah, you can make any noodles.
Wait.
In fact, what we're gonna do is...
How long does it take?
We're gonna...
Uh...
We're gonna make Vite Ramen noodles.
Oh!
But I didn't get the branded one, because this is my personal statue.
You can make any kind of...
You can make any kind of noodle, and it's the same thing, right?
This is how you know Doki has never struggled.
Okay, I just get a kettle and pour hot water in the noodle.
I...
I never...
We got the water in?
I had a kettle, guys.
All you gotta do, water, noodles, microwave.
We go three minutes, and then afterwards, we're gonna give it a flip.
And then, uh, and then that'll be good.
Oh, I see.
Yup.
A kettle, ooh la la, so fancy Doki.
A microwave is more expensive than a fucking kettle.
La-dee-da, this fancy.
Alright.
We got a salmon.
Yeah.
We got...
We gotta get a little tomato there, obviously.
A little...
That cuts the acidity.
We'll go with some more green onions, because green onions are good on everything.
We gotta do the fancy cut again.
Oh!
A fancy way!
Look at him go!
Right?
I'm gonna put that...
right on the rice over here.
But wait!
We wanna make it cuter!
Wait, there's more!
You're right!
Oh wait!
There's more!
And so...
We are...
Where the hell did those go?
Oh!
And so...
This...
is how you make...
the bento apple bunny.
Oh!
Teach us!
First of all...
Clear your board.
A little bit.
Yeah.
Then you cut.
Down the middle.
Whoa!
So fast!
Down the middle again.
And then...
With these...
So...
One of the easiest ways to do it in order to...
First of all...
Yeah.
You wanna core it.
So you can...
So you can do something like this in order to core it.
Yeah.
You can choke up on the blade over here.
Fun fact!
Actually...
The iron sights actually help with this.
Because...
In...
In tactical knives.
When we...
When you have tactical knives.
You do actually have these kind of things over here.
So you can rip the...
You can rip someone's insides out better.
When you twist it, right?
No!
It's...
It's for...
So your hand doesn't slip.
Oh!
And so...
This not only...
That's what jacket knives do.
I forgot.
That's a jacket knife.
Okay, so you'll...
I guess technically if you put this in and then you pull it out, I don't know what that would do.
Yeah, because...
Yeah, you can just like rip the insides out a little bit more.
But that's also what jagged knives do too.
Yeah!
Yeah, anyway.
So don't ask how I know this, guys.
But anyway, so what do we...
So...
What do we do now?
Then we just cut it so it's flat on the surface over there.
And then you can choke up on the knife in order to make this easier.
You wanna...
And then you wanna...
What you can also do is you can cut that...
You can cut that flat in order to make it easier on yourself.
Yeah.
And then like this, because we're using a bigger knife, we're just gonna have to cut it a little shorter.
Just so it's easier to work with.
Oh my God.
I wanna close up, camera.
It is also...
Camera three!
Give me a close up.
All right, nice.
Thank you.
Right?
Yeah.
And then we cut over here.
Oh, actually we...
So you first do a V cut over here.
Yeah.
Lightly.
Across.
So you score.
Boom.
And then boom.
Yeah.
And then you go in between...
And then you go underneath, just under the skin.
Ooh.
Guys taking notes, guys.
And what you wanna be careful of, especially if you're using a big blade, is...
It's very easy to go over here and you'll see that this will actually cut through over here instead of...
So you kinda gotta angle it.
Yeah.
Downwards as you're moving.
Slowly.
So fancy.
Angle.
And then...
This pops off.
And it's a...
Oh no, I broke it!
I broke it!
No, never mind, I didn't.
It's fine.
And it's a bunny!
And it's a little bunny.
Look at that!
Don't ignore that.
It's Hollow Knight confirmed!
Guys, we're gonna get the sequel, guys.
Okay, yeah, and then you do that again.
Yeah, we're just gonna...
We're gonna make two because we don't want this...
We don't want this guy to be lonely, right?
This is unconfirmed, guys!
Look at that!
Alright.
And then we're just...
Ah!
What?
What happened?
Oh, you broke it!
No, no, no.
It just...
I just nearly cut myself.
Oh yeah, that's also equally bad.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
I...
I might have...
Yeah, no, I messed this...
I mean...
No, never mind.
We have just this one.
This is perfect.
Look at that.
Look at that little guy.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's...
This man is bleeding on our bento.
No, that's...
How dare he!
Hey, hey!
That's new expensive stuff, okay?
That's...
That's the flavor.
Extra flavor.
Ow!
That's hot.
So yeah.
That, right?
Then the noodles in the microwave, and then you get...
You know, you stir them around a little bit, and then you microwave it until it's done.
Uh-huh.
Until you're...
To how...
How done you like it.
Easy.
I do another three minutes, personally.
I like making noodles softer.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
Otherwise...
Voila.
Camera two!
Here is a...
Close-up.
Western...
Um...
Here's a Western...
Uh...
Style...
Bento-ish...
With a...
With a clam chowder.
Um...
Uh...
Clam chowder.
Corp bullion poached lobster.
Oh!
Salmon...
Uh...
Um...
What do you call it?
Fusion...
Fusion salmon.
Apple bunny.
Um...
Apple...
Or...
Tomato rice.
Uh...
Yeah.
A clam chowder bento, guys.
There's so much in there!
Oh my god.
Wait.
That's it?
That was it?
Yup.
Oh my god.
And that is...
Look at all the stuff that we can make with microwaves and the doki blade, the doki board, put in bentos, and you can take that to work and take that to school.
Yeah!
Guys, and he made...
And eat it with your doki chopsticks.
He made all of that within an hour and 30 minutes.
Wait, that's crazy.
He made so much stuff.
Look at all the shit he made, guys.
With 10...
Guys, all we need is just 10 microwaves.
Is that easy, chat?
It's true.
That's all you need.
Which one do you want me to try first?
I want you to try...
Try the chicken first.
Try the chicken?
Yeah.
I was gonna eat it with the knife and then I was like...
No, that's not safe.
That's not...
Even I wouldn't recommend that.
Wouldn't recommend what?
Eating the chicken?
No, eating it with the knife.
Oh, well, okay.
Now I have to eat it with the knife.
Don't do it!
Tim!
It's so sharp!
Oh, my God.
You're fucking crazy.
This is something even I couldn't even endorse, guys.
Oh, my God.
Guys, don't do this at home.
This guy is...
This guy is not okay.
Look, you can just cut into that tomato.
Scoop it.
Guys, oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
Maniac.
I guess...
Guys, don't do this at home.
Don't do this at home.
He's a CEO.
You know how them CEOs are like, guys.
Hey, other CEOs.
I want to see you do this, okay?
You might...
You know?
Just saying.
It's a kill issue.
The world might be a better place.
Yeah.
Oh!
The fries are so good!
Guys...
Wait.
It's because of the MSG.
Mmm.
Wait, is the rice really good?
Yeah, this is the high-line chicken rice.
That we made with the...
With microwave, guys.
Yeah.
And with the stock.
Oh, man.
Doki, you need to try making this.
Oh, my God.
The first thing I do, I was gonna make that rice.
The microwave rice.
Someone, like...
All right.
Someone sent...
Someone tried to buy me a rice cooker.
But then, like, on the Throne website thing.
But then, like, Throne was stopped him.
So, thank God.
So, now, I can just never have a rice cooker again.
I can just use a microwave.
All right.
It's okay.
I'm gonna send you...
I'm gonna send you a rice cooker.
I...
I can't...
Wait.
I can't believe that you don't have rice cooker.
Wait, but why?
Why wouldn't I have a microwave?
The microwave can do everything.
It's...
It's the principle of it.
Okay?
Even Throne didn't want me to have a rice cooker.
They stopped him.
They were, like, something...
Why did they stop it?
Because Throne was like, there's something wrong because there's a price difference, apparently, from Canadian, apparently Canadian rice cookers were more expensive than like wherever country that guy tried to buy it from.
So they're like, we need you to pay to pay the extra cost so we can send this rice cooker to you.
And then I was like, hmm.
Hmm.
Okay.
As I am.
I'll send you like the tiniest rice cooker.
So now I don't need a rice cooker.
I have the mic... you prove your point.
No, it's okay.
You prove your point that microwaves are better.
I actually think the microwave cooks rice faster than the rice cooker.
I'm not even...
See?
It does like at least 20 minutes in the rice cooker and it's like 12 minutes with the microwave.
That's half the time and it tastes just as good.
I've been enlightened.
I've...
See, guys, 12 minutes in the microwave and all you need is rice and water.
Faster but not better.
This man was a Michelin chef.
He endorsed microwave rice cooking.
You know what?
If you don't think it's better, come find me.
Yeah.
What's your address?
Let's go.
Yeah, fight him, Ira.
It's on the Byte Ramen packets.
So you're gonna have to buy her stuff and then once it gets there, then you have the address.
For legal reasons, do not travel to the Byte Ramen headquarters to fight an Asian man.
Do not do that.
But if Tim tweets that out on his own social media account, I can't stop you.
But if it's on my channel for legal reasons, that is a joke.
Do not...
Do not find where the headquarters are.
I mean, it's like public information, technically.
I'm not there all the time, though.
Tim, you are not helping yourself.
If you really, really want to dox yourself right now in front of all these people,
legally, maybe you should do that on your own channel.
Look, I'm not saying you should come and, like, help me.
Legally, he's not threatening you guys.
It's all a joke, by the way.
I'm not...
I'm not saying that, like, I have a lot of stress and anger to release, but...
In Minecraft, right?
In Minecraft, yeah.
Yeah.
Like, this is clearly... this is clearly a Minecraft.
Yeah, I got some Minecraft.
Yeah, guys, in Minecraft.
If... on my channel, it's in Minecraft, guys.
Wait, why do you have a sword in your kitchen?
Uh, so I actually have a lot of swords in my kitchen.
Don't worry about it.
It's, you know, let's... it's for choice.
You know, like, if...
Wait, can you cook with that?
If someone comes...
Can you cut a chicken?
Yes, I actually have...
Yes, I can.
Cut the chicken!
Wait.
That's... that is literally why I...
We're supposed to be selling a Doki plate, not a...
No, no, no.
Wait, cut the chicken.
It doesn't matter.
What are they gonna do?
Buy that sword?
We're gonna... we're gonna cut that...
We're gonna cut this on the Doki board, yeah.
Yeah, you just cut that... cut that chicken.
Wait, how sharp is it?
Everyone got some good angles?
It's not too sharp because, uh, swords need a different geometry.
Um, but...
Is it cake, guys?
Is...
Is it cake?
All right.
You guys ready?
Yeah.
I'm ready.
Three...
Two...
All right, let me...
Let me actually...
I don't wanna stance this.
Guys, he's a poser.
Doesn't even know how to hold this...
Whoa!
What do you mean?
I'm a poser!
I can't believe you would say that!
That is a dull-ass knife, not gonna lie.
That's a dull-ass knife.
Yeah, and that's why.
Now show what it's like with the Doki blade.
See, you got...
Look, compare it.
This is a before and after.
Yeah.
Chat.
It's actually...
Oh my god, I'm gonna have to wash that after.
And now, if we do it with the Doki blade...
Watch.
Yeah, look at this.
Ooh!
Look at that!
You see?
You can't do that with the clay more.
Look at that!
Ooh!
More like a mash more.
Honestly, I'm hitting...
I'm like hitting into bone everywhere, so it's not really cutting.
Whoa!
Look at that!
Look at that cut!
So smooth.
Did you hit it?
Oh my...
Whoop!
Coby!
Yeah, so there's a bone in there.
There's a lot of bones in this.
That's great!
Oh!
Thanks for showing us, Chef Tim, on how to make...
How to make two bentos with ten microwaves.
That was a great time.
Yeah, and remember, everyone, you need to go buy the Doki Blade, because I have a lot of lawsuits I need to take care of.
Yeah, and I'm one of them!
Wait, close up on the blade!
Close up!
Camera two!
Camera!
Show that blade!
Guys, yeah, so all the stuff we've cooked with the tools we used.
That's the wrong camera, Tim.
That's...
There you go.
So you can buy all these equipment, or pre-order them right now, including the Doki Blade, the Bento Box, the Chopsticks, and the Doki Boy!
Yeah!
Look at him go!
Also, this can...
Oh my god, he's doing it again.
Also, after all that...
Oh my god.
It can still shave hair.
Fucking crazy.
Because this is VG10, it is hardened to 61 HRC.
I know those don't mean very little to people, but I am a knife nerd.
Also, I will be coming out with a full explanation, where I just rant about how the knife was designed and all of its features and all that kind of stuff, so look out for that.
Yeah!
Also, I...
Oh my god, I damaged the shit out of this one.
Wait, did you do it?
Was that right over the Bento?
What?
No, I...
No, I did it over the board.
I'm just...
Oh, okay.
There's some pretty deep cuts in the board now.
That knife...
That...
The sword's pretty...
Actually...
Oh, shit.
That's not even that bad.
Oh my god, wait, hang on.
I gotta show you guys this.
Oh, wait.
Like, for a Claymore?
For a Claymore slamming onto this thing?
This is...
That's a thick-ass Dragoon, though.
Yeah.
You know, we...
We like the Dragoons thick.
Look at that.
Camera two.
Would you...
Look at that.
Would you think that this cutting board got slammed on by a Claymore?
Like, look at that.
No, look at...
This is...
This is real hardwood.
This is real pieces of hardwood.
Like, you can...
You can see the grain.
This isn't, like, painted on or anything.
That's...
You can use it as a shield.
Or...
You can.
Sort of.
Yeah.
Yeah, actually.
Hey, Sean, you got your arrows?
You wanna...
Okay, maybe not here.
Maybe not.
Maybe not here.
Maybe on your own channel.
That's fine with me.
Yeah.
They put hard in hardwood.
I didn't say that.
I didn't say that you did.
From chat.
Yoink.
My joke now.
Yup.
And so...
I like where I'm like, ah, yes.
Look at...
Look at this.
That's filled with all the oil and all the stuff.
This is how you know I have ADHD, guys.
Like...
This is when you can tell it's...
It's the real deal.
With all the stuff.
Real cooking!
Yeah!
All those cooking shows.
And everyone's just like, ah, yes, I got a pristine kitchen all the time.
What are you doing?
Like, are you, like, cleaning every single time?
Like, what?
That's not what real cooking looks like!
This is what real cooking looks like!
That's normal!
That's okay!
Yeah!
But if your kitchen looks like this, you're doing good!
You're just cleaning afterwards!
That's the worst part, though.
That's the worst part about cooking.
It is.
But hey!
And unfortunately, I got shit everywhere, so...
Yeah, that's very unfortunate.
I'm gonna clean that up.
Thank God you have Terrence here to help you.
And Leo.
You go, Leo.
You think that food was free?
No, it's cleaning time.
Yeah, they do get to be fed all of this afterwards, though.
So, you know.
That's gonna be pretty good.
But yeah, it was fun!
Yeah!
Yeah, thanks for hosting.
And if you ever...
And remember, buy the Dogi Blade and...
Yeah!
You can do the end chilling part.
Yeah, guys!
You can buy...
You can pre-order all that merch right now on the Vite Ramen collab store.
It's literally pinned in my chat.
Wait, I'll just spam the link right now.
Because I can do that.
All right.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Let me...
Okay, let me grab the link real fast so I can spam it.
All right, guys!
Click on this link and you can pre-order now!
For your very own Vite Ramen and DogiBird collab merch items.
Like the Doki board, the Doki blade, the bento boxes, the chopsticks.
Am I missing anything?
Is that...
Yeah, that's...
Nope, that's...
Yep.
That's all, folks!
Yeah!
So you can get one yourself, too!
But thank you, Tim!
Let's see if I can...
Thank you, Tim, for...
Yeah, thank you!
...for doing this stream with me.
That was really fun.
I learned a lot today.
Okay.
Wait, can we...
Hang on, hang on.
I need to do this real quick.
What are you doing?
Yeah!
Yeah, you can 360 no-scope your food now, Chad, with the iron sights.
Oh, God.
Please...
Please don't.
Oh, yeah.
How long would the pre-orders be up for, Tim?
So we're keeping pre-orders...
So what we usually do is we keep pre-orders open until we start to see, like, everything is starting to drop off.
And then we go, hey, final call, if you missed it.
And then we put in our orders.
Okay.
But how long would that usually be, in your opinion?
Usually...
Yeah, usually that's...
Usually that's after I finish yapping about knives.
So probably a month.
A month?
Okay, yeah.
So you have a month to pre-order these.
So a month to save up if you're actually...
If you're looking forward to grabbing these before the pre-order ends, guys.
But thank you, Tim.
It was a pleasure to be here.
I had a great time for this cooking show.
It was a great experience.
I think Chad loves it.
Chad, did you have a good time watching Tim hurt himself for our enjoyment?
And remember to say thank you to the tomato that gave him skin for this?
Yeah, Doki.
You had a great time.
Yeah, check out Vite Ramen.
Check out Tim, the CEO of Vite Ramen.
All right.
But thank you, Tim.
Yep.
Thank you.
And now...
I'll do an ending intro.
I need to clean up.
Yeah, you do a clean up while I do my ending thing.
All right, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around and get that blood flowing.
And you stay up for us, me, Tim, and I.
Head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.